hello cpac do you miss me yet do you
miss me
a lot of things going on
to so many wonderful friends
conservatives and fellow citizens in
this room and all across our country i
stand before you today
to declare that the incredible journey
we've begun together
we went through a journey like nobody
else there's never been a journey like
it there's never been a journey so
successful
we began it together four years ago and
it is far from being over
our movement of proud hard work
and you know what this is the hardest
working people hard-working american
patriots
is just getting started
and in the end
we will win we will win
we've been doing a lot of winning
as we gather this week we're in the
middle of a historic struggle for
america's future
america's culture and america's
institutions
borders and most cherished principles
our security our prosperity and our very
identity as americans is at stake like
perhaps
at no other time
so no matter how much the washington
establishment and the powerful special
interests may want to silence us
let there be no doubt
we will be victorious and america will
be stronger and greater than ever before
[Music]
i want to thank my great friends matt
and mercedes schlapp
matt thank you
thank you mercedes thank you very much
and the american conservative union for
hosting this extraordinary event they're
talking about it all over the world matt
i know you don't like that but that's
okay
all over the world i also want to pay my
love and respect
to the great rush limbaugh
who is watching closely
and smiling down on us he's watching and
he's loving it and he loves catherine
catherine thank you for being here so
great thank you katherine he loved you
catherine i will tell you that
so fantastic thank you catherine very
much
to each and every one of you here at
cpac i am more grateful to you
than you will ever know
we are gathered this afternoon to talk
about the future of our movement the
future of our party and the future of
our beloved country
for the next four years
the brave republicans in this room
will be at the heart of the effort to
oppose the radical democrats the fake
news media and their toxic
cancer culture something new to our ears
cancer culture
and i want you to know that i'm going to
continue to fight
right by your side
we will do what we've done right from
the beginning which is to win
we're not starting new parties
you know they kept saying he's going to
start a brand new party
we have the republican party
it's going to unite and be stronger than
ever before i am not starting a new
party
that was fake news
fake news no
wouldn't that be brilliant let's start a
new party and let's divide our vote
so that you can never win no we're not
interested in that now we have
tremendous uh
mr mclaughlin just gave me numbers that
nobody's ever heard of before more
popular than anybody that's all of us
it's all of us those are great numbers
and i want to thank you very much those
are incredible numbers i came here and
he were giving me 95 97 92
i said they're great and i want to thank
everybody in this room and everybody all
throughout the country throughout the
world if you want to really know the
truth
thank you though thank you
we will be united and strong like never
before
we will save and strengthen america and
we will fight the onslaught of
radicalism socialism and indeed it all
leads to communism once and for all
that's what it leads to
you'll be hearing more and more about
that as we go along but that's what it
leads to you know that
we all knew that the biden
administration was going to be bad
but none of us even imagined just how
bad they would be and how far left they
would go he never talked about this we
would have those wonderful debates he
would never talk about this we didn't
know what the hell he was talking about
actually
[Applause]
his campaign was all lies talked about
energy i thought i said you know this
guy actually he's okay with energy he
wasn't okay with energy he wants to put
you all out of business he's not okay
with energy he wants windmills the
windmills
the windmills that don't work when you
need them
joe biden has had the most disastrous
first month of any president in modern
history that's true
already the biden administration has
proven
that they are anti-jobs
anti-family
anti-borders anti-energy
anti-women and
anti-science in just one short month
we have gone from
america first to america last you think
about it right america last
there is no better example than the new
and horrible crisis on our southern
border
we did such a good job it was all worked
nobody's ever seen anything like we did
and now he wants it all to go to hell
when i left office just six weeks ago we
had created the most secure border in
u.s history
we had built
almost 500 miles of great border wall
that helped us with these numbers
because once it's up you know they used
to say wall doesn't work well you know
what i've always said
walls and wheels those are two things
that will never change
the wall has been amazing it's been
incredible and little sections of it to
complete they don't want to complete it
they don't want to complete little
sections in certain little areas they
don't want to complete but it's had an
impact that nobody would have even
believed it's amazing considering that
the democrats number one priority was to
make sure that the wall would never ever
get built would never ever happen
would never get financed we got it
financed we ended catch and release
ended
asylum fraud
and brought illegal crossings to
historic lows
when illegal aliens trespass across our
borders they were promptly caught
detained and sent back home
and these were some rough customers i
want to tell you some rough customers
were
entering our country it took the new
administration only a few weeks to turn
this unprecedented accomplishment
into a self-inflicted humanitarian
and national security disaster
by recklessly eliminating our border
security measures controls all of the
things that we put into place
joe biden has triggered a massive flood
of illegal immigration into our country
the likes of which
we have never seen before they're coming
up by the tens of thousands
they're all coming to take advantage of
the things that he said that's luring
everybody to come to
america
and we're one country we can't afford
the problems of the world as much as
we'd love to we'd love to help but we
can't do that so they're all coming
because of promises and foolish words
perhaps worst of all joe biden's
decision to cancel border security has
single-handedly launched a youth migrant
crisis that is enriching child smugglers
vicious criminal cartels and some of the
most evil people on the planet you see
it every day just turn on the news
you'll see it every day
under my administration we stopped the
child smugglers
we dismantled the criminal cartels we
greatly limited drug and human
trafficking to a level that nobody
actually thought was possible and the
wall helped us a lot